willow non je ne vous entends pas vous
appris sur une boîte et cette blague est
bien bien nul on est en plein tournage
mal stb bonjour bonjour à vous comment
allez vous n'avez pas quitté cette vidéo
après cette magnifique intro je vous en
remercie peuple d internet aujourd'hui
je vous parle d'un jeu pour cette
quatorzième ouverture du calendrier de
l'avent c'est émoticônes challenge ils
ont fait pas mal de version de ça et je
trouve celle ci très drôle c'est smileys
voir des images et fait ça je vous donne
un exemple très concret jouons ensemble
c'est beaucoup plus simple
catégorie film tout le jeu et que en
émoticônes et en catégorie et il faut
trouver de quoi ça parle
là vous voyez par exemple l'image
l'héroïne eh bien il faut deviner le
film alors qu'est ce qu'on a on est
maudit connu nous avons quatre tortues
un rat un point un peu bagarreur et des
pizzas
c'est donc tortues ninja le film tortues
ninja celle ci elle est facile à
maquillage un requin des dents des dents
de la mer les dents de la mer les dents
de la mer oui très bien il y en a plein
comme ça dans toutes les catégories s'en
prend au hasard on essaie de les trouver
ok ça c'est quoi c'est la catégorie ce
jeu alors il faut retrouver un jeu vidéo
je suis pas bon du tout je sais pas dans
quoi je m'embarque pas bon du tout enjeu
bio mais quand même celui ci est celui
ci je commence déjà à avoir des doutes
il y avait un jeu
de trucs de ninjas ou fallait couper des
fruits aha
bravo sherlock le des fruits à ninja je
crois que c'est un jeu de ninja fallait
concept et ce jeu c'est cool on a un
débat avec loïc -qui tourner la vidéo
est qui et qui la montrent d'ailleurs je
peux vous prouver parce que là il va
faire apparaître des fruits et il a le
jeu original que je n'arrive pas à
trouver
il est déjà en train de mettre en post
prod on va s'appeler c'était un jeu sur
iphone non et tu dois faire ça avec
voilà on va passer donc à ce jeu là une
étoile j'ai envie de dire star non je ne
suis pas bilingue et un micro chanter
singstar match comme ça bon bref vous
avez compris que je suis surtout une
grosse brel en jeu vidéo
passons à la catégorie suivante
catégorie séries là il ya un
extraterrestre un acquis qui donne un
coup de langue comme s'ils avaient mangé
un chat mois spontanément je pense à
half sais pas si vous avez connu la
série half
mais du coup j'ai envie de vérifier sur
le voir si j'ai bon pas parce que bien
sûr vous avez toutes les réponses ici
halff
je lis je le suis fier de moi 1986 à
1990 j'ai une culture très récente
un dernier pour la route on va aller
dans les livres dans les livres alors
diffuser des extraterrestres planète des
gens malades y meurt et de l'argent
on a trop fait un film pour finir allait
enfin se refait un film pour finir à la
halle à un extraterrestre un vélo une
usine à téléphone maison téléphone
maison ici je vais à phil même pas des
manchots sur le douche un couteau salle
cause d'alfred hitchcock
j'ai beaucoup aimé le principe de ce jeu
en fait c'est quand j'ai vu la boîte ça
m'a fait kiffer parce que là tu vois
spider man là tu sais que c'est titanic
ici men in black is his exemple the city
si harry potter je trouvais ça très
malin en fait comme idée novateur j'ai
jamais entendu parler d'autres jeux
comme ça donc de fait je me suis dit ce
serait bien de l'art en parler parce que
ça peut leur plaire tous moi je dis
jamais le prix des choses j'ai payé ça
j'ai payé ça la somme exacte de 10
euros/mois trouve ça sympa ça se joue
entre amis où ça peut se faire donc avec
des vraies règles pour marquer des
points à tous où ça pue juste se faire
comme ça entre potes sans chercher à
compter de crohn juste chercher à
résoudre l'émoticône challenge j'ai
trouvé ça cool
vous pouvez me dire si vous aimez bien
vous pouvez cliquer cette vidéo vous
pouvez vous abonner à cette chaîne tout
ça se fait d'une manière gratuite
vous pouvez retrouver le lien de ce jeu
dans la description le lien est gratuit
le jeu est payant j'ai pas d'action
c'est pas un placement de produit et
vous pouvez revenir sur la chaîne demain
matin à 6 heures pour une nouvelle vidéo
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est comme ça
c'est un calendrier de l'avent salut
ciao
je m'en vais
[Musique]